this episode is sponsored by Squarespace
go to squarespace.com microcosmos to
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
[Music]
within the little droplets of water we
study each week on Journey to the micro
Cosmos we have seen all the chaotic
aspects of life that we experience on a
macro scale unfold between the tiniest
of organisms and through them we've
learned plenty of lessons as stories of
resilience and adaptation unfold before
us like little microscopic Aesop's
Fables
but Aesop probably would not have come
up with one of our favorite morals of
the microcosmos never let anyone
convince you that butts immortality or
sex are easy to define or describe
now if we were going to write our own
Fable to get this more lacrosse it would
have to Star the freshwater cnidarian
called the Hydra one of our favorite
stars of the micro Cosmos because in the
Hydra the question of butts connects to
the ambiguities of immortality which in
turn relates to the befuddling matter of
sexual reproduction and in some species
it builds to a fantastic reality where
sex spells the beginning of the end
but that's jumping ahead let's start
with what's usually the end of the tail
the butt which in the Hydra also doubles
as the mouth and for hydras defining the
mouth and the butt is a bit of a
complicated affair because much of the
time there is no opening at all the area
where the mouth belongs is a continuous
sheet of cells that ruptures open and
expands when the time comes to eat or
poop imagining for a moment our own body
is working that way is horrifying
there's the fact that the food would
enter and exit our bodies from the same
location and then there's the wound
inflicted from within to make that
possible but for hydras this is casual a
part of their daily habit of recycling
cells and making new ones that makes
their bodies capable of handling all
sorts of things their ability to do this
is rooted in the populations of stem
cells that are able to endlessly divide
to make different types of cells that
can patch the Hydra up theoretically a
Hydra could replace all of the cells
along its surface within a week now
there's a number of philosophical
questions you could ask about this is
the Hydra like the hypothetical ship
whose every part has been replaced by a
new piece and if so is a Hydra with new
cells still even the same Hydra it seems
like we would have to say yes especially
because it maintains the same sequence
of DNA that molecular source of identity
that so often seems to Define us but
then what to make of a Hydra that
reproduces asexually butting off new
little clones of itself that swim away
carrying that same DNA are those clones
part of the same original Hydra or are
they their own entities we could argue
those questions all day and perhaps some
of you will but we're asking them not to
get to an obvious answer but to instead
have a little fun with the fact that our
definitions inevitably fall short of
what nature actually reveals as far as
the murkiness in nature goes Hydra butts
might be a little unusual but they are
practically straightforward compared to
the question of immortality we've
actually done an episode about
immortality before and in it we said the
following
and these stem cells make the Hydra
biologically Immortal because its cells
are always being replaced the Hydra is
able to avoid the accumulation of damage
that other multicellular organisms
experience the Hydra doesn't age and so
until another force or Predator
intervenes it doesn't die
well we sure did say something that
sounded uncomplicated there but it turns
out we were a little bit wrong not
entirely wrong just not entirely right
either and this is where the complicated
question of sex comes in this is Hydra
viridissima a species found throughout
the world and that's notable for the
green color it gets thanks to the
chlorella algae living symbiotically
within it and along this hydra's body
you can see Tiny round structures with
something wiggling inside those wiggling
bits are immature sperm cells waiting to
burst from the organ that encases them
eventually the sperm are released by the
Hydra into the water in search of eggs
to be fertilized most of the Year none
of that is happening the Hydra
viridissima will reproduce asexually
butting off its little clones but when
the weather gets warmer the population
shifts individuals develop gonads that
mark it as male female or hermaphroditic
and for the female hydras asexual
reproduction is put on pause and that
all sounds very simple and like it
follows a clear cycle but it's also very
specific to this species if you ever
want to feel your brain turn completely
to Mush read a few scientific papers
about Hydra sex it's not that Hydro sex
is particularly complicated in its
mechanics it's just that it's very
difficult to say any kind of generality
about the strategy and effect of sexual
reproduction in hydras across species
some species spend most of their life
reproducing asexually some alternate
between asexual and sexual reproduction
some rely on populations of
hermaphroditic individuals others have a
mix and still others have individuals
that change their sex and that's just a
few of the details
hydroveradissima for example are called
warm crisis hydras because they tend to
shift towards sexual reproduction when
the waters get warmer in general a shift
from asexual to sexual reproduction
marks an attempt to survive through
variation creating eggs or offspring
that might be able to weather the
challenges of an environment that a
population of clones might not so for
the hydroviridissima as Waters get
warmer the possibility of droughts or
shifts in their food might signal the
need to become sexual reproducers but
for other species of Hydra it's not
warmth that triggers the switch it hold
the oncoming winter that makes their
environment harder and informs their
decision to change to sexual
reproduction this species Hydro
oligactus for example has become a
useful model for researchers to study
because all the hydras need to be
convinced to reproduce sexually is a
little chill in the water and yet hydras
are nothing if not wildly inconsistent
with one another which means there is
another species hydrofulgaris that can
begin reproducing sexually within a few
days of its birth with little care for
temperature of the water at all however
the most meaningful inconsistency of all
ties into one of the long-standing
debates about hydras are they immortal
so what does immortality have to do with
sex well for some hydras nothing but for
others it's everything including the end
as we said before hydras can of course
die there are predators and forces of
nature they cannot Escape but aging well
that seems like something they've never
had to deal with before because of that
pool of constantly renewing stem cells
within them and for some species we've
talked about today like hydrovironisoma
and hydrofulgaris those pools of cells
just keep on churning keeping the
animals ageless
but for hydro oligactus our cold weather
reproducer a switch to sexual
reproduction puts a halt to all of that
when the temperature drops and the Hydra
begins to produce its sperm or eggs the
rest of the animal begins to decline as
well the cells within it begin to
descend into disarray and over time the
Hydra will start to eat less and less in
the lab they will usually die within
months but why there are a myriad of
Pathways within the animal that seem to
describe Hydra oligactuses sudden but
slow shift from an immortal to an aging
animal and yet these changes in gene
expression and behavior don't fully
explain why this species is so affected
by the switch to sexual reproduction
While others like hydroviridissima are
able to switch to and from different
methods of reproduction without any
aging at all buried in that mystery are
the answers to so many of our questions
about how aging affects our own bodies
and perhaps someday we will find those
answers nestled in between
contradictions created by our own
attempts to define the world to
understand it as best we can with the
tools we have available to us imperfect
as they might be
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you to
Squarespace for sponsoring this episode
Squarespace gives people a powerful and
beautiful online platform from which to
create their website whether you're just
starting out or looking to grow your
existing business Squarespace has
everything you need to succeed so let's
say you're looking to create a stunning
online store for your fashion brand with
Squarespace you can create a beautiful
and professional looking website that
showcases your Unique Style and brand
and with the help of their third-party
extensions you can easily manage
inventory streamlined bookkeeping and
ship products across the world and if
you're interested in blogging about your
fashion brand Squarespace makes it easy
to create a blog that seamlessly
integrates with your online store you
can share your latest collections style
tips and behind the scenes glimpses into
your creative process with your readers
with Squarespace you can also interact
with your customers and build a
community of fashion enthusiasts through
threaded comments and replies sign up
for a free trial at squarespace.com to
start building your online fashion
boutique today and when you're ready to
launch visit squarespace.com microcosmos
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain
the people on the screen right now they
are our patreon patrons they're the
people who make it possible for us to
continue exploring the truly bizarre
nature of the world that we get to live
in It's a Wonderful World and the more
we look the more bizarre we find it to
be so thank you to them for helping us
do this work if you would like to become
a patron on patreon you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
thank you
foreign